>> Tucker: YOUR SOCIAL BETTERS
HAVE A HABIT OF BEING A POSTURE.
YOU NEVER REALLY BELIEVED IT.
NOW YOU KNOW IT'S TOTALLY FAKE.
THE CHINA NBA STORY PROVES A
PEER BY THE WAY, THE UKRAINE
IMPEACHMENT SAGA ALSO DOES.
EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON IS
TELLING YOU IT'S UNBELIEVABLE
THAT DONALD TRUMP WOULD HAVE
USED A CONVERSATION WITH A
FOREIGN LEADER TO HELP
POLITICALLY.
THAT NEVER HAPPENS.
WE ARE NOT ENDORSING IT BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE YOU SOME
CONTEXT SO LAST NIGHT WE SHOWED
YOU A PHONE TRANSCRIPT WHERE
BILL CLINTON WHO WAS THE
PRESIDENT ASKED TONY BLAIR WHO
WAS THE PRIME MINISTER OF
GREAT BRITAIN FOR POLITICAL
BOOSTER FOR THE 2,000 ELECTION.
WE WEREN'T SINGLING OUT
BILL CLINTON.
THIS IS VERY, VERY COMMON.
NOW JOHN KERRY HAS BEEN TALKING
TO ANYONE WHO WILL LISTEN ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT'S SHOCKING
BEHAVIOR WITH UKRAINE.
WATCH.
>> MY REACTION IS ONE OF
ABSOLUTE SHOCK AND THE BASEMENT.
THAT IS A FUNDAMENTAL PROFOUND
ABUSE OF POWER.
THERE IS NO OTHER WAY TO PUT IT.
>> Tucker: NO OTHER WAY TO PUT
IT.
CLICHE.
HE'S FULL OF IT.
YOU KNEW THAT.
BUT JUST TO PUT SOME MEAT ON
THOSE BONES, DURING THE 2004
ELECTION, WHICH HE LOST,
JOHN KERRY OPENLY BRAGGED ABOUT
FULL SITTING SUPPORT FROM
FOREIGN LEADERS AGAINST HIS
OPPONENT THAT YEAR THE INCUMBENT
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH.
I'VE MET FOREIGN LEADERS WHO CAN
GO OUT AND SAY THIS PUBLICLY BUT
BOY, THEY LOOK AT YOU AND SAY
YOU'VE GOT TO WIN THIS.
YOU'VE GOT TO BEAT THIS GUY.
WE NEED A NEW POLICY.
PEOPLE LOVE JOHN KERRY.
HE WAS ASKED TO WHICH LEADERS
TOLD YOU THAT JOHN KERRY?
WHAT'D YOU SAY TO THEM WHEN THEY
SAID THAT?
AND WHAT NEW POLICIES DID YOU
PROMISE AND HOW DID THEY PLEDGE
TO HELP YOU?
JOHN KERRY SAID HE WASN'T GOING
TO BE SPECIFIC BECAUSE IT WAS